Justin Timberlake and Jessica Biel
continue to be the cutest couple
well ever it's visually JT's at 38th
birthday and check out this Instagram
video he posted Wednesday night totally
calling out Jessica for getting a little
cab nap in I'm just preparing for our
big night out okay so no word yet on
what they did to celebrate but I can
totally relate to Jessica for needing a
little snooze before a big night out and
here's the thing JT and Jess being cute
on insta is nothing new there was also
this time when they posed with Mickey
Mouse this epic Halloween night out with
son Silas all of this PDA this Cirque de
Soleil handstand situation and oh yeah
who can forget plant slash knife gate
boom get some that's a three and that's
not all they've also been super adorable
in joint interviews with et and we may
have dug up some fun clips for you guys
every topic did you pick this outfit no
no no I just saw me I just admired we're
on out we were on our way here and I was
like I win everybody go home well I have
my own gold statue it already you were
doing some good crowd control over there
I'll set your way you know what they
need to be tamed they're a little unruly
they only got unruly when you arrived
oh no they're uh they're obviously
easily impressed
you get ready together do you help each
other what's the process yeah we do I
mean we always are curious with the
other person thinks of course and we
kind of like to match a little bit
sometimes but you know I always say if I
if if my wife is impressed before I walk
out of the door I'm a winner before the
nights over
they're so cute - you said so much of
your new music was inspired by your wife
and your sign
no wait is that you that we hear a
little bit on the album somewhere fess
up it may or may not be my wife I'm
letting him answer this one I don't want
to get in trouble
really I have an example he is it I
don't get to see I don't get to have any
of the songs you know I have none of the
album really just in case something
happens I don't want to be the one
responsible and getting leaked and it's
on my phone it's all coming out soon
it's all coming out soon just give us
like a look probably a little bit maybe
she is probably a little bit maybe she
is I mean could they be any more perfect
probably not let us know all the things
that you love most about Justin and
Jessica and of course be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm Katie Krause and bye for now
[Music]